So, that was a harsh winter in crypto.
But, let me tell you the good news.
In crypto, specifically Bitcoin,
historically, it comes in 4-year cycles.
We get 3 years of party, green candles,
everyone's happy, cash flying from the
sky, and then we have 1 year of sadness,
hibernation, and down only, which is
what we are almost at the end of right
now. And so, if you're planning to ride
the lovely next 3 years back to Bitcoin
all-time highs and way beyond, like I
am, we need to know what the bottom is
actually going to look like cuz there
could be one more big pullback, or we
could be going up from here. So, I want
to break down the five top bear market
signals for you to watch to make sure
that you're not going to miss this
bottom. Because if there's a bottom to
miss,
it's not this one.
This video and all other videos on this
channel are for entertainment purposes
only. Modern financial instruments,
including crypto, are highly volatile,
and the majority of retail clients will
lose money. Do not invest any capital
you're not prepared to go to zero. So,
before we jump into these specifics, I
really love zooming out and getting
perspective on the whole market. When
you look at Bitcoin yearly candles, you
can relax. You can be a lot more
peaceful. If you're looking at the
trenches, if you're looking at your old
coin or altcoin portfolio, it's tough to
be peaceful. It was rough. But, have a
look at this. This is 3 years of lovely
up from Bitcoin, 1 year of pullback. 3
years of up to all-time highs, 1 year of
pullback. 3 years of up to all-time
highs, 1 year of pullback. 2 and 1/2
years of up we had to all-time highs
once again, and we've had almost 1 year
of pullback.
Honestly, it's not a bad niche to be in
when you realize that 75% of the time we
are, on average, trending up. And if
you're watching this video right now,
this is not the time of the market where
retail is here. You are not retail.
You're a believer in crypto, you're a
believer in Bitcoin, you're probably a
believer in this rainbow chart knowing
that Bitcoin is going to keep going in
this direction and it's going to be
rescuing a lot of people from poverty.
It's physics. Study Michael Saylor. He's
going through a rough time at the
moment, but if you're a Bitcoin
believer, you understand that this
market is coming back. It's just a
matter of when. So, I want to walk you
through these five indicators starting
with the strongest of all indicators,
especially based on what happened at the
top close to the end of last year, the
four-year cycle. Now, this is a graphic
I've shown many times on the channel and
I have an updated one for you. This is
not the updated one, but this just shows
you historically the four-year cycle in
Bitcoin, 3 years of absolute wonder, 1
year of depression, 3 years of wonder, 1
year of depression. Almost to the exact
day. In fact, it's within a week range.
1,064 days of wonder, 364 days of
depression. Now, where are we right now
before we hopefully rejoin this
four-year cycle? If you project out the
1,064
days of up, 364 days of down, you can
see the top was the 5th of October.
Meaning, once we get to the 5th or even
the 4th of October for 364 days down,
that is the projection of the turnaround
zone. October 5th, 2026, which is
closing in on double-digit days. It's
just over 100 days as we talk about it.
And if you want to time this out, like
you can see this with the chart right
here. Literally, the highs on those 3
years of up for the last three times.
So, this is not a promise, this is not a
guarantee, but everyone who's out of the
four-year cycle in the past, including
myself, have been wrong. And honestly,
I've sensed that it's become a
self-fulfilling prophecy because people
expect it to go up on that date. People
are more sure of themselves, more
certain, start buying, goes up, they're
like, "Told you so." More people jump in
and it's this lovely thing where we're
actually getting green candles again.
Now, 100 days from now is the turnaround
zone, October 5th, 2026. That is a time
to look for. However, if you watch
Benjamin Cowen, if you watch some of
these analysts who have been right even
in the big pullback, they're saying that
there may be an event that could
front-run all of the losses. For
example, Michael Saylor, there's rumors,
we don't know how true they are or not,
that he might be in some trouble in
terms of liquidity. If he's forced to
sell and Bitcoin tumbles down to 48,
down to 38, down to 35, or wherever it
would go in a forced liquidity event,
you can no longer wait for the big
pullback on October 5th in the
turnaround there. Because the losses
have actually front-run the schedule, so
that may take the risk out of the
market, which we're going to go into
risk in just a second, early. So, you
can either look for the capitulation in
terms of time or capitulation in terms
of price. If we do get something like a
war or a Michael Saylor who is forced to
liquidate a lot of his Bitcoin, which
honestly, I don't think that's going to
happen, but it's possible. Now, experts
are also predicting one more counter
rally trend, which doesn't mean we're
going to get a counter rally trend. No,
but in the last two pullbacks,
we've had three counter rally trends
before it made all-time low. At the
moment, a counter rally, you can see
this is right here. It went from 80 up
to 98. People like, "Oh, it's not a bear
market after all. Super cycle, let's
go." False. It was a bear market down to
58, where we are right now, down to 60
basically. Counter rally, back up to,
which is honestly a crazy return if you
can play these rally trends. But now, it
has crashed once again down to about 58,
where I'm currently recording this
video. It is expected to have one more,
but they are really hard to time and
really hard to know if it is a counter
rally trend or it is the market turning
around. But, when we project out the
four-year cycle, we don't have much time
for that counter rally trend. We've got
October coming up extremely soon, right
here where this box starts, before the
projected three years of green. Now,
it's not up only. You can see even on
the green in the last cycle, it went to
71 and pulled all the way back to 51.
People got scared before it went up to
108, pulled back to 75. It's not smooth
running, but on average it goes up in
these 3 years. When the year we're
currently in, on average it goes down.
There is some time for this one last
counter rally trend. Maybe it pops back
up to 73 or something like that, and
then pulls back for its final low.
Honestly, if you want my personal
opinion, I'm not an expert like the
quality experts. See what they say and
pass it on to you guys and trade it for
myself. A lot of experts are saying 48.
A lot of experts are also saying that's
absolutely completely crazy and it won't
actually touch 48 because we're already
below the 200-day moving average, which
I'm going to show you in just a second.
Some people are also calling for, "Okay,
once it touches the 30s, people are
going to be like all the risk is taken
out of this. It's an absolutely absurd
price, especially when you can factor in
inflation, which we're going to go
through in the end of this video."
Anywhere in this zone, or some people
like 60 was the low. Right now, we're at
58 and I'm going to show you a couple
other graphs, but we're at some pretty
crazy lows in terms of some factors to
look at. Let's just jump into them right
now. So, that was the first bottom of
the market indicator, which is just
timing. The second one is called Bitcoin
MVRV
score. Now, this is a fascinating one
because every time it's hit zero or gone
below zero, the market has officially
bottomed. So, it's a relative indicator
used to measure how much Bitcoin's
circulating market value deviates from
its realized market value. And you can
see right here, back in, let me get the
data on this 2019,
the bottom, and you can see the green is
the MVRV Z-score. You can see it dropped
there to -0.44,
which marked the bottom of the market.
You can see the next bottom of the
market down here in 2022, which these
are the same years of the 4-year cycle.
It's 2019, 2022. And you can see the
bottom over here was -0.19
before it started going up as the bottom
of the market. Right now, the score is
still in the positive. It's positive
point two two. But, you can keep an eye
on this to see once it crosses past
zero, that normally and historically has
indicated the bear market turning. The
next one is an interesting one. This
comes from Crypto God John, who is a guy
who's still and I'm going to show you a
couple of these in the bear market, the
big pullback especially with alts, is
calling some bangers and still printing.
And so he's an impressive guy and he put
me on to something called which is his
favorite indicator and a strength signal
called the Coinbase premium, which means
what is the price of Bitcoin on
Coinbase, which is one where retail
buyers, but two, where big companies
with big treasuries are also buying
from. And so if the price on Coinbase is
lower than the price in the free market,
you can see that these retail and big
industrial brands are not buying. In
fact, they're going to be selling,
pushing the price down. However, if
there's a premium in Bitcoin, and you
can see down here, this is where Bitcoin
was priced higher on Coinbase, there's a
lot of demand for Bitcoin on Coinbase,
people buying it up and the price goes
up. And it's only a fraction, so you can
see if we zoom in right here,
point two percent lower at the moment,
which is actually a decent amount lower.
And you can see that right there is the
delta. That's the difference of price on
the free market verse Coinbase premium.
You can see it's low right now. So the
lower that gets, it shows the bottom of
the market is in. This is it back in
2020, showing the Coinbase premium price
at massive spike low right at the bottom
of that bear market. Now, the next one
is called the Bitcoin realized price.
Now this is a really strong one as well.
This is what is the average realized
price that all Bitcoin holders bought
their Bitcoin for. And you can see at
the moment the realized price is 52,816
dollars, which of course you know right
now the Bitcoin price is about 58,000.
And you can see anytime that this
crosses over, the market shortly has
turned around. Right here, it's crossed
over. Right here, it's pulled back and
crossed over. You can see it crossed
over here, which it did spend some time
under the average realized price before
absolutely accelerating. So, it's not an
instant indicator, but it shows it could
be a good time for myself, no over
financial advice here, for myself to
dollar cost average if I'm not already,
which I'm going to talk to you about my
thoughts in just a second. Again, it
crossed under here before accelerating,
crossed under briefly here, accelerated,
crossed under here, accelerated, about
to cross under again to mark the bottom.
Now, on this channel, we like to trade
social arb. Social arbitrage is
basically what is a narrative or what is
the story going on with the mainstream
that we can get ahead of. And right now,
the mainstream story is crypto sucks,
crypto's over, there's a big video that
crypto's is a scam, and then finally the
whole market's crashing and going to
zero. Guys, this is some crazy
impressive technology. Bitcoin,
honestly, is one of the best inventions
in the last century, and it's going to
do a lot, and it already has done a lot
of good. It's going to continue to do a
lot of good for people who need it. And
right now,
a lot of people disagree. A lot of
people are in extreme fear, 17. And
historically, I don't have to point this
out, but literally every time you cross
into extreme fear, historically has been
a good time to buy. Once again, you
cannot time this perfectly. Well, you
can, and good luck to you because it's
possible to do, but you don't need to
time this perfectly. You just need to
time this with a long enough time
horizon that it's okay to grab Bitcoin
at 58, even though it's going to drop to
48 in a month from now, and then go back
up 58, 68, and all the way up to
all-time highs, where it's projected to
go in the next 3 to 4 years of green
candles. But when the consensus becomes
it's a good time to buy Bitcoin, it's
already factored into the price. So, you
need to buy when it's not a good idea on
most people's watch. And you can see
tweet volume for both Bitcoin and
Ethereum are at all-time lows. You you
keep an eye on that to see if that's
turning around or not. This is new
weekly views on YouTube for the top
crypto channels. You can see at the peak
back here late October 2024 and early
Jan 2025, it was at about 5 million
views a day. It's currently down at
about 1.3 million views a day. So, it's
a long fall off. If you look at Google
Trends, this is for YouTube search
volume. You can do YouTube Google Google
search volume, should I say? Google
search volume, not YouTube Google search
volume. You get what I'm saying, I hope.
You can search for YouTube or you can
search for Google. This is YouTube
Analytics. Crypto is absolutely off its
all-time high down to just 25%, so a
quarter of the demand. Bitcoin's at 16%
of its demand and Ethereum is literally
down so far. Ones and twos, Solana down.
And obviously, when you plot these over
their price, it basically matches
one-to-one. So, as the demand comes
back, the price will also continue to go
up. That's what's happened historically.
Now,
cool. We're due for Bitcoin to start
turning around sometime between now and
the next 100 120 days. Not that long,
especially considering how long we've
waited. But, even in the pullback,
there's been some massive opportunities.
And even in the pullback, you've started
to reveal to ourselves where the good
coins are and which ones are never
coming back and have taken 99.9% hits to
the face. And we're just influencer
coins that, yes, are very volatile, but
remember, they are also the ones that
are volatile to the upside next time
that market comes back. And I'll show
you a couple of opportunities actually
in this video, too, because even though
the market's pulling back, it's not like
there's no opportunities. There's just
less opportunities. And the more money
that keeps flooding back in, and then
the more views that keep flooding back
in, these opportunities just start to
multiply. And as we are smart and we
know what we're doing, especially as we
learn every single cycle, we know which
tokens we can buy and hold for longer
term and which tokens we got to get rid
of as soon as we see
a multiple on our money from investing
in it. Because I hope you recall the
crypto whip where the biggest tokens are
the least volatile in both directions.
This is what we said all throughout the
last cycle. The lower the market cap,
the higher the potential upside, but
also the higher the potential downside.
So, when Bitcoin falls 50%, you may see
a 99.9% on some crappy influencer
altcoin. But, if it was to be the other
way around and Bitcoin were 2 or 3x,
you're going to see some rocket ships
going in your altcoin portfolio. We just
need to know where we are in the market
to know where the portfolio should be.
And at the moment in the market, we are
in this area for a large percentage of
my portfolio, 85 + % of my portfolio.
These tokens will make their way back,
but they're also easier to replace. So,
something in here, like this was a three
bull gaming, I forget exactly the name
of this one. I don't actually know how
it's doing. Not talking about this one
specifically, but in the next cycle, in
the next 3 years of up, maybe it might
come out in 2 months, maybe it come
might come out in 6 months and get a few
influencers behind it. It could easily
be replaced and cloned where Bitcoin,
Ethereum, Solana, XRP, these are ones
that have massive cult-like followings,
massive holders, and they're not going
to be replaced as easily. And like I
said, there's been some really big
opportunities. Even in my inner circle,
I've been talking about hype for so long
since it was literally down in the $20
range. And in the biggest bear market,
the big down year, what has it done but
absolutely performed extremely well?
Honestly, so impressive and so strong
into the top 10 cryptos. If you have
been dollar cost averaging this
alongside me, congratulations. We are
quite happy with that. You have other
strong tokens that are up the crypto
whip, something like Aerodrome Finance,
which has a strong use case, a very
awesome team,
performing really well recently. You've
got VVV Venice token coming out of
absolutely nowhere into the top 100
tokens performing extremely well like
there is no bear market. Of course, one
of my big holdings
took a took a hit. It did not have the
5-year super cycle, but it has held very
strong and I'll say this,
it's down a long way from all-time high.
It's down less from all-time high than
other meme coins that don't have a solid
base of holders. I am holding this token
because I think it's performed well for
a bear market, which sounds ridiculous
because it is down but it's probably
like down 80% or something. But, it's
not down 98% like a lot of other meme
coins and therefore it's showing its
resilience, it's showing its holder
base, it's having the people who are not
believers once again have their money
change hands. Let me zoom out on this
graph a bit and let's have a look at the
absolute bloodbath that we have
hibernated through. Extremely good job
getting through this, but in my opinion,
it's had so long to have everyone who's
not a believer get out and when the
market comes back, which we know cannot
be far from now, the tokens with the
biggest believers and the people who are
less likely to sell are going to
outperform the ones that are new tokens
with paper hands, everyone trying to
make a quick dollar selling on top of
each other. Now, down the risk curve
even further, we talked about this
opportunity here as well and of course
in our inner circle, it became the
official mascot of SpaceX. It's called
Asteroid and it absolutely exploded.
It has had a big pullback and even on
the SpaceX IPO, it has not been able to
withstand a lot of sell pressure. Now, I
don't think this is a good token to get
into. It might be, it might not be. I'm
not personally getting into this one.
I'm just showing you that there has been
decent opportunities even though the
market has been down. This is another
decent opportunity and some got sent 10%
of this token. It's called the Ansem
Blackbull token and you can see
even though the market's been slow,
there's been opportunities and honestly,
inside our inner circle, we've sent out
opportunities almost at a higher ratio
of success and multiples than last year
when the market was green. Just because
people are more choosy with the tokens
that they're getting into and everyone
seems to consolidate on those same ones.
So, there are some massive opportunities
still there right now. And as we
continue to climb, this was a one of
Crypto God John's recent calls inside
Iron Circle 2 that went to a $52 million
market cap. There are less tokens and
they go less high, but there is
opportunity out here and the opportunity
as Bitcoin and the market turns. Once we
hit that inflection point and it turns
around, these are going to be even more
frequent. Now,
my personal thoughts. One, Bitcoin at
58, Bitcoin at 50, Bitcoin at 45,
whatever Bitcoin's at, you have to
remember we're not even adjusting this
price for inflation. Inflation has been
crazy, monetary inflation has been crazy
over the last 5 years. And you can see
the Bitcoin, the actual Bitcoin
inflation price rate here has it listed,
which is basically when you measure the
M2 money supply, the amount of money
that has been printed in the world
versus the price of Bitcoin, we're
actually looking at a $35,000 Bitcoin
right now. Which to me, when you look at
just pure physics, when you look at
scarcity, when you look at whatever the
most sound money is attracts the most
money, this is my number one place that
I want to put my money. I think there's
going to be an amazing upside here, but
I need to have a long time horizon. I
can't think in months, I can't think in
weeks. I have to think in 10 months.
I said I can't think in months, but you
know, 12 months, 1 year, 2 years, 3
years. And this to me becomes such a
no-brainer. Especially because the M2
money supply is going to continue to
expand. Second of all, crypto's been
quiet, there's been some nice
opportunities, but we've also had, like
crypto is a technology that we've been
given in order to help us get ahead with
asymmetric upside. The other technology
we've been handed really recently is AI.
So, I've been diving deep into AI
because I think the people who know AI
the best, people who know how to
leverage AI the best, are going to
inherit the world. Especially if you
think AI is where I'm going to make a
lot of my money, and crypto is where I'm
going to multiply that money. That is
how I plan to conquer over the next 10
years. That is what we're doing inside
our inner circle. And we're also having
something called asymmetric bets because
I do think with inflation, with the way
the world is going, with taxes, and all
these people wanting to take your money
from you, the only way to get ahead is
not a nine-to-five job. It's not working
at time for your money. It's creating
asymmetric bets. So, whether that be
altcoins when the season's hot and you
got an influence behind them, or having
an asymmetric business with AI infused
into it, that is what I'm currently
focusing on, and I'm excited to run back
the next three years with you, capturing
as much of this opportunity for our
community as possible. Thanks for
watching. I'll see you soon.